right hello
i'm steven schroeder and presenting with
me today is
sylvia haas hello welcome to our talk
about new courseware tools
sylvia works on the deployed products
and services team
and she was one of the camp directors at
the 2020 wolfram summer camp
i am in document and media systems
and i was also a mentor at this year's
wolfram summer camp
so far at wolfram my main projects have
been the computational essay template
and form notebooks which are both coming
to wolfram language in 12.2
what brings sylvie and i together for
this talk is that our projects
both have the goal of bringing more
tools to educators
using wolfram language all right
so today i will be talking about
form notebook i'll go over the basics
about what it is and then i'll kind of
go over
the main parts of it and a quick live
demo
and some quick blurbs about
what is going to go on with form
notebook in the future and then sylvia
will talk about question framework
so form notebook a form notebook
has three main components the first is
a special authoring environment which is
then built into
the second component which is a
user-facing form notebook
and the third component is an
association of users responses to the
form
might sound a little confusing right now
but i'll it'll all make sense in a
minute
so an author can choose how they want
the user's responses to be recorded
and responses to a form can be
automatically sent to the author's email
stored in a data bin
or kept in a cloud object
typical uses for form notebook
include creating quizzes surveys polls
lectures but there are a million ways
that form notebooks can be used
for example in addition to what i just
mentioned
form notebooks can be used to gather
metadata or configuration details
that feed into another program or for
data logging
storing to cloud objects data bins etc
so now that you know the basic
idea of what a form notebook is and does
i'll go a bit into detail
into each of the three components that i
mentioned earlier the authoring notebook
the user form notebook and the response
association
okay so the authoring notebook
is where the form is created as an
author of a form
this is where all the magic happens
within the authoring notebook
you can insert form elements or editable
notebook areas
so for example this right here is a form
element
um and form elements and editable
notebook areas have an author defined
key
that identifies the response in the
response association
so for example the key for this form
element is name
and for this one it's question one
and you can also in the authoring
notebook choose what to do with recorded
responses
using the settings menu again all this
all
be showing live in a couple minutes
so the second component is the user
notebook
so after uh the author clicks generate
it'll create this user notebook where
all of the form
elements are built into interactive
forms so
for example this first form element
where it's the label is please enter
your name and then it's asked looking
for a string
it'll build into the form object
right here where it prompts you and
a user can go through any of this
answer all of it and then once they
click submit
whatever the author defined in the
settings
of the authoring notebook that will
happen
when the user clicks submit so
whatever the author wants to do with all
of the responses
submit will actually do that thing
so all of those
form elements and help notebook areas
are scraped which creates an association
where the keys are the author defined
keys that i mentioned before
and the values are the labels and users
responses
like i said based on what the author
defined the association is sent to their
email data bin
whatever and here's an example
association
from the sample that i had in the last
two slides
so for example the key here is name
and then it has the label and what was
provided
as an answer um
just an extra details that all contents
within editable notebook area are
scraped and included in the response
association
so i will do now a live demo
so here is an example
notebook which is very similar to
what you will be seeing
[Music]
the final version in 12.2 has a few more
features that will make authoring easier
but all of the main components are here
so again you can see
each of the form elements and then here
you have
the editable notebook area that i was
talking about so
anything that is put in between these
brackets will be scraped and all the
cell contents will be included in that
response association
so i will add another form element here
so maybe
we want to ask um
rate your overall understanding
of image processing
using wolfram language and i'll add
a slider so here i'll
use the drop down for the insert bar
and add a slider and i'll
change the key to question four
and the label i'll make
rate and any number between 1 and 100
and so you can click this button to see
what it'll look like
in the auth in the user's notebook
and you can go back and forth and that
all looks good to me
i think i like how i've made my quiz
here's a quick example of what
an annotation will look like it won't be
built into
the user's notebook now before i go into
the user notebook i'll just take a look
at the settings
so i've adjusted the background color of
the user notebook
and what i want the doc cell text to say
and you can also customize
in this little dialogue
what you want to do with that uh
association the scraped association so
the default is create dialog but there's
a bunch of
other options that we have in a mini
library here
so you can submit it to a data bin send
an email
copy it to your clipboard for today's
demo i'll just leave it on create
document stephen sorry to interrupt
sure could you increase your
magnification and maximize
your windows that you're using getting
some requests in chat sure
um yeah i'll increase
this and i'll click
generate and then i'll also increase
this so here we have the
um user notebook and
i'll put in my name and you can see how
the docked cells adjusted with the
colors based on what i specified
and maybe i'll put some responses here
and rate my understanding here
so now uh as a user
i would click submit and then whatever
the author had defined will happen
like i said i just had it set to create
document
so it's going to create a document with
that scraped association
in it so let's go for it
and make this nice and big
so here's the association so the name
and then it has the label for the form
object
and my response and here's that response
that response
and for the editable notebook area you
can see that
we get a cell expression back it's not
super pretty
but that is the complete cell expression
of these two
images right here and then at the end
you can see
um what i rated my understanding
which was 46 out of 100.
okay if there are any like questions i
can go back to this demo
at the end um
but for now i will conclude my part by
saying that as this
project goes on there's going to be more
author tools and submission options
and in the future after 12 2
there will be a q a form notebook which
has dedicated question types and uses
the new assessment function and question
object frameworks
and it has diy courseware creation
with special question
interfaces and so to talk about some of
that stuff i will
hand this screen share over to sylvia
all right um hi so i'm sylvia
um and steven mentioned before but i
work on the deployed
products and services team um and i
started
this spring um and i've been focusing
on the courseware tools um but mostly
the question framework which is what
we're going to talk about today
um and just so to give you an idea of
like how it fits in
with what steven's been talking about
right so
he was just talking about more of the
front end and now we're going to talk
about
the back end so it won't be as pretty
but it does some cool stuff
um so the
um question framework sort of going to
fit in
with these q a form notebooks
so when you get those response
associations
it will grade them
so let's start talking about the pieces
in question framework um so first up
is the assessment function um
and that's the graded tool grading tool
so
it's going to be an automated
grader um for a quiz test
lecture questions um
and it has a bunch of cool options um
you can have uh like element wise
assessment which allows for things like
partial credit
you can include explanations for why
an answer is correct or not you can have
tolerances and distance functions
so you don't have to have just one right
answer
you can allow for
some variance in that for example
if you had a question asking for a
specific location
if a student put an answer that was
within 50 miles
you could count it as correct but there
are a bunch of
different functions and options that
allow you to customize
assessment function to do all sorts of
cool things
another aspect of it is that it has
built-in comparison methods
so for things like tolerance or distance
some of these things like vectors date
objects
city locations are going to have that
just built into it already
which is the cool part of full frame
language is that it has so many of these
things
built into it um so the second part
that i want to talk about is assessment
result
object so assessment function and
assessment result object
are both planned to be in 12-2
and if assessment function is the
greater assessment result object is the
grade
so when a student provides an answer and
you run it through the assessment
function
you get back this association full of
interesting information for teachers and
students
it's going to have the grade that they
got with their score
um it's going to have whether they were
right or not
of what the the target answer was if
there was an explanation provided
that'll be in there
and we'll see examples of these in just
a second
um and a third thing i wanted to touch
on um that's not in 12
2 but sort of bundles them all together
is question object which is
going to tie together a prompt or an
actual question
with an assessment function so you don't
just have
a grader floating around not tied to
anything um
and that will fit in nicely with these q
a for notebooks
so let's jump into a demo here um
i'm going to start with a question from
one of steven's
notebooks it was just the first question
on his
slides and it was a multiple choice
question so
the assessment function for this might
look something like this
it's gonna have our three options one of
them is going to be true
the other two are false and if we run it
it will give us a cute little assessment
function
um so if we run it with our answer here
um i want to be right first so if we run
it through there it will give us
a correct answer we get our little check
mark that we know are right
um and let's test it with the wrong one
um but these have all sorts of other
information in them
so if we want to know what our score was
we can see that we got one
um right if we test it here
we got zero points um and you can easily
create
one so if i want to say that if i'm
wrong
i get negative points and if i'm right i
get
positive score if we run it now
i get three points or negative one
points
um so that's just sort of like
a multiple choice one right answer
example
um so another example here for
one with tolerance if our question is to
write out
an approximation of pi i'm not a teacher
but i'm also not very picky so
if they get it within
.01 of the right answer
i'll accept it i'm a nice teacher
uh you can see that it's accepting
numbers
so if i'm a super student and i give it
a great number
it loves it if i give one that's not so
great
it's gonna say that i'm wrong um and
you can use all sorts of tolerances you
can use
a distance um and play around with those
as well all right so um one more option
um or example of the many options of
assessment function
are you can use patterns or entities
so right you don't want to have to write
out all of the different options
you can just use the built-in patterns
and entities that
are already in wolfram language so
you can ask a student to provide an even
number for example
if we run this we give them the answer
too
we love it but if we say three
or it's angry um and
similarly we can do it for something
like name a european country
using the entities and then if we give
it germany
it's it works so
to build off of that a little bit i just
wanted to show you
the partial credit and element-wise
assessment
so instead of just listing one country
um you can have them list
multiple countries so and grade each of
those
independently so let's run this
and if we run our example here it gives
us this
which we know are right but i think it's
more interesting if we actually look at
what's inside of this
let's just look at everything um
right you can see that our score is two
where
it's default is one point per correct
answer
um and we got two um overall we were
correct
this was what the student provided there
was no explanations from the teacher
but we also get a breakdown of all of
the different
scores and whether they were correct per
answer
so if we put in one that is incorrect
you can see that our last option was
false which will give us
an overall false because we have to be
correct for the whole thing by default
um but for fun
let's throw in another option here so
if we type in answer
correct
a very short option and then
we can say that if any of them are true
we will accept them
okay um so if we run that
it should give us this answer correct
should turn from false
to true like magic
okay so right you can customize all
sorts of things
there are a bunch of options um
but moving forward um
right there are quite a few comparison
methods already in there but
there are so many more that could be
added to allow for
this this like built-in concept of
tolerance and
yeah so more comparison methods
um as well as allowing for remote
assessment
um right so that the
the answers aren't baked into the
notebook um you would
send them to the cloud which would be
hopefully helpful for teachers to grade
things their students can just submit
them
to the cloud to get created and get um
their grades back that way but also
working with stephen moore to integrate
um the question objects
and the form notebooks so
um we're gonna move on to q a
now if you guys have questions um so
that wraps up the talking part um but
also with us
you've heard him speaking with your your
comments
um is arvin from education partnerships
to help answer any questions that you
guys have
so send us questions and chat we would
love to hear
your thoughts comments this stuff is all
in development so
we want to hear from you
so we have a comment from seth chandler
asking kind of about
textual responses and what sort of
powers we might have for grading those
so would you like to take that sylvia
i have some feelings but you're the
developer
so yes um
there's there's not a lot of things so
like
spelling i feel like there can be all
sorts of things that could be
built in for that we don't have anything
i don't think right now
but right like if they capitalize random
letters or
spell things weird or um
yeah giving sort of like a distance for
spelling
um i think it's definitely possible yeah
i mean
theoretically at the very least you
could do some kind of like
uh string pattern matching that looks
for the word in a response
but i think for a lot of like more
complicated questions
you're just gonna need to take a look at
it
yeah i mean in theory there are a lot of
things that you could do
with kind of analyzing textual responses
like you're asking about
a specific court case um
so you could see you know does this
person's response contain
certain words or phrases that should be
there
or you know does it have some specific
length that you think it really ought to
have if it's going to
you know be a sufficient answer um you
can ask all sorts of questions about
that text
but those sorts of things you would have
to kind of generate those
tests for the text yourself currently
at least yeah
[Music]
we have another question from kelvin
asking about
uh we have any examples where the
interpreter
is for an expression so the question
would grade computations created by a
student
and then we could see uh and grade
whether they wrote the computation
correctly
uh yeah definitely um there's
um things in the works right now to
just like grade like just any wolfram
code
so like um
you can have right you can write code in
so many different ways but having it
all have the same is it doing what you
actually want it to do
there's a whole code comparisons for
that yeah there's a whole branch of
people working on
code equivalents that will hopefully be
um eventually a part of the stuff that
is going on here i i think something
that's uh exciting on
is you know sort of related to
expressions a little more specific
from educators i've spoken to and from
my time teaching
is because of the generality of wolfram
language you could ask students you know
give a symbolic answer in terms of pi
you could ask them give a numeric answer
to such and such precision like sylvia
showed off
you could say give the answer as a
fraction
or you know give the nearest uh you know
give the nearest fraction within some
tolerance
there's there's kind of a lot of freedom
in
the specifics you can ask for that you
usually don't get from current like
computational grading systems
which i think is really useful in terms
of you know mathematics and physics in
particular
i'm biased because that's where my
background is but
students and teachers both really don't
like these grading systems online where
you go in and the student has to you
know
type in 3.14159 for pi
or however many digits they want and
then they have to type it in a specific
way with a specific
number of decimals to get the right
numeric answer so we can
totally avoid all of that and do things
in a much more elegant way
okay some more questions coming in
from pathable uh michael
don't mind my cat who has just woken up
and is now walking around meowing
because i'm not petting her
she was asleep when the meeting started
i'm so sorry kaden
um so michael impathable asks is there a
way to dumb down mathematica
so they were to ask a student what is
sine of pi over 6
can we make sure that they type in
one-half
or 0.5 and not sine pi over 6 and have
that evaluate
to you know evaluate
to the actual value
if that's not i think yeah i think the
goal of
the comparison types is that you can
sort of narrow down what exactly you're
looking for
the full documentation for assessment
function is quite impressive um sylvia
only showed a very small portion of what
it can really do
so i'm looking forward to seeing that
there are many many options and
functions and
you can customize it as much as you want
see
uh so there's another question by phil
um i think after reading it
the impression i get is that
he's looking for some kind of like
if a student answers a certain way is it
possible to have the rest of
the assessment or quiz or whatever
kind of adjust to the way that the
student answered the first question
um i think the answer to that currently
is
no but i think
that is an interesting idea and
i'm happy to take a note of it i think
it
it seems like it could be nice i know
um in the q a form notebook one
uh feature that is planned to be
included
is that if you you can have
hints in like included in questions
and you can also have feedback so say
you
answer incorrectly to a question
you can set it to give some kind of
feedback saying oh that's not the right
answer
maybe think about this so hopefully that
kind of answers your question
i see that david has
asked if we would be able to recognize
and compare graphs and plots and i have
a suspicion but
i will leave that to you too
i feel like that will fall under like
the code equivalence
for right now so um
if they type in the code for it then yes
and that can be you know i guess this is
going to be worked into the
code options but even off the top of my
head i can think of ways to be like
did they type plot such and such from
this initial value to this final value
and then you know if they put in options
you could even ignore the options as
long as they typed in the right code
yeah am i wrong to say that there's also
direct graphics
comparison as long as they have typed in
the same code i think that's less useful
though
i think we can be around for a couple
more minutes we can go
over time a little bit so if you guys
have any more questions we can
uh we can be around
maybe we can give it a couple more
minutes if they're just to see if
they're
any further questions
phil asks can i generate questions from
templates
with different parameter values for each
question instance
i see so right so randomizing
a test for example
this is a feature that uh
i hope that we include eventually i
think
the way that form notebook is going to
be included in 12.2
that's not going to be there but
hopefully
that will be a feature that
is eventually included and hopefully
will just be included
base with the q a form notebook as soon
as it comes out
i feel like the next talks are starting
so yeah we should let people go
yes thank you guys so much for coming
and for all your great questions yes
thank you all
have a good afternoon